à slamer ou mcnabb et comme une colline
le 18 mars dernier nous étions tous émus
touché de voir la tunisie
déstabilisé par une attaque terroriste
qui a ciblé un emblème de la tunisie
cette attaque apparemment a été réalisée
par une vingtaine de personnes dans neuf
étaient sur place sur site et mire
imaginons maintenant que une attaque
d'une telle envergure puisse être
réalisée à distance depuis des milliers
de kilomètres à travers les réseaux de
communication et les réseaux
d'information
c'est justement l'histoire du film black
hat qui est sorti il ya quelques
semaines et qui sait un film de michael
mann
c'est un film qui parle d'un d'une
attaque qui va cibler une centrale
nucléaire en compte qu'à travers une
attaque plus ou moins sophistiquées donc
c'est un film qui aura t'il qui se
rapproche beaucoup de la réalité selon
les critiques
cette histoire là c'est pas totalement
de la fiction parce que c'est une
histoire qui il qui est inspiré de la
réalité inspirée d'une attaque qui a été
réalisé en 2009 part à travers une
campagne d' attaques cybernétiques qui a
visé les systèmes nucléaire iranien à
travers un virus un programme
extrêmement développé qui s'appelle
stuxnet
stuxnet où il ya plusieurs variantes
dans par exemple flame du coup à gauche
et c'est cette attaque là a réussi à
retarder le système le programme
nucléaire iranien de presque 3 ans donc
ce n'est plus de la science-fiction
sunna plus ce n'est plus de la fiction
mais c'est de la pure réalité
donc on a doublé tout ce qu' il ya des
organismes d'intérêts vitaux ça veut
dire les systèmes de transport d'énergie
les systèmes de télécommunication le
système boursier
beaucoup de banques financiers etc sont
des systèmes sont aujourd'hui
névralgique et qui prouvent qu'ils
peuvent être ciblés par des attaques
spécifiques qui vise la disponibilité
ou l'intégrité de ces services là alors
imaginons il y a quelques jours
la turquie a plongé dans un black out ce
blackout aulas a causé l'arrêt de
plusieurs services dont par exemple les
transports le métro etc
il y à des rumeurs aujourd'hui le
premier ministre turc n'a n'a pas
tranché n'a pas encore décidé où la
halle enquête n'est pas encore terminée
mais la piste d'une cyber attaque
réalisée par des des attaquants ou
des pirates informatiques iraniens n'est
pas encore exclue ça a été la même chose
à sao paulo en 2009 où c'est le pays ou
la ville et plonger totalement dans le
noir pendant des dizaines d'heures et le
scénario de la cyberattaque a été un
scénario étudié la même chose il y à
quelques il ya quelques semaines
quelques mois en fin de 2014 une art ce
riz en allemagne a été ciblé par des
pirates et a causé des dommages
importants selon leur rapport allemand
également sur la ligne de pipeline sur
la mer caspienne
une attaque a été réalisée par des
pirates en 2008
cette attaque la lors de l'explosion
donc les systèmes d'alarmé les systèmes
de supervision les caméras ont été
bizarrement désactivé il n'a pour le
moment aucune trace
allez hop
voilà alors des attaques d'une telle
envergure sont réalisés au goût
également d'une façon plus large la vol
de spanair chic chic et 50 22 en 2008
selon le rapport qui est apparu sur sur
le journal espagnol el país il a cité
quatre au gendre quelqu'un introduire
introduit un trojan pour déstabiliser le
système de guidage de l'avion lors du
raid israélien sur le réacteur al kibar
en syrie en 2007 lors de cette attaque
là les systèmes sol air et syrien a été
déstabilisée désactivé donc là il ya
quelque chose qui s'est fait juste avant
l'attaqué
alors tout ça pour vous dire quelque
chose qu'aujourd'hui les cyber attaques
le cyber espionnage d'ici là les
cyberguerres ne relève plus de la
science fiction ou de la fiction elle
même semé sont bel et bien là d'ailleurs
l'isis l'état islamique a créé une
entité qui est ça qui s'appelle hacking
dvg de l'état islamique et qui a réalisé
certaines attaques pour par exemple
prendre le contrôle de du compte twitter
youtube de l'us central command qui le
sont rarement des usd l'armée de désuet
pour le moment ils ont réalisé également
d'autres attaques qui par exemple pour
exploiter certaines vulnérabilités sur
le web pour prendre le contrôle offert
le défi semaine des as des des sites web
pour le moment ces attaques là ont été
réalisés en exploitant des
vulnérabilités plus ou moins connus mais
ça pour le moment
premières traces des cyber guerre
c'était en 2007 donc lorsque il y avait
un événement diplomatique entre
l'estonie et la russie où les historiens
ont déplacé une statuette d'un endroit à
un autre donc pour se venger
plusieurs russes se sont manifestés en
faisant des attaques
plusieurs groupes d'attaqué russe pour
déstabiliser tout le système système
internet de l'estonie et mettre des
centaines voire des milliers de sites
web lèvera logique hors service
mais ça c'était avant il y à quelques il
y a quelques semaines il y a juste
enfin un toute fin de 2014 une grande
opération de cyberespionnage a été
réalisée par les russes pour anticiper
et voir le sommet de l'otan qui était en
train d'être préparée au pays de galles
concernant seule l'intervention russe en
russe en ukraine
un système qui a un groupe de pirates
informatiques qui a de très bonnes
relations apparemment avec le
gouvernement russe a pu collecter des
informations depuis
l'otan depuis des ambassades des
gouvernements des académies des grandes
entreprises d'énergie en exploitant des
vulnérabilités les premières traces des
activités de ces groupes de pirates date
depuis de 2009 cela veut dire que de
2009 à 2014
ces personnes là ont agi sans qu'on
puisse les détecter en toute fin de 2014
également nous avons vu la tacc des
nord-coréens la vengeance nord-coréenne
contre corps contre sony pour avoir
financé le film the view qui critiquent
le leader nord-coréen
donc les nord-coréens en réaliser une
attaque pour par exfiltrer des
informations depuis sonypictures ils ont
extrait un énormément d'informations et
les états unis et leurs alliés ont réagi
en faisant tomber les connexions
internet en corée du nord nous pendant
plusieurs heures entre parenthèses les
attaques qui ont été réalisés ont
exfiltré énormément d'informations donc
par exemple des informations concernant
des scripts concernant des des rapports
de rendement sur la fois sur les
salaires des employés sur les sur les
films sur des côtes source desservir le
manque à gagner est l'impact est
extrêmement important des centaines de
milliers d'emplois sont en jeu et c'est
pourquoi l'administration américaine à
ce moment là a pris l'initiative et a
pris l'initiative de répondre à une
attaque qui a ciblé une entreprise aux
états unis mais également même parmi les
informations on peut trouver le numéro
de téléphone de brad pitt
c'est pour toutes celles et peut-être
ceux qui sont intéressés il faut dire
que les quatre ne font pas uniquement
des actions malveillantes de toute façon
alors les cyber des cyber armée
aujourd'hui sont organisés à travers des
unités extrêmement organisés extrêmement
entrée d extrêmement loti de un ensemble
d'outils par exemple une unité très
connu qui l'unité 61 3 99 33 98 pardon
de l'armée populaire de chine qui a
réalisé plusieurs types d'attaqués en
asie et ailleurs d attaque de cyber
attaques ou des attaques de cyber
espionnage industriel
donc aujourd'hui on dit que plusieurs
états se sont organisés pour créer des
cyber armée par exemple on dit que la
corée du nord aujourd'hui à 3000
personnes qui sont là pour réaliser des
attaques cybernétiques
la chine aurait dix mille personnes les
américains cible avoir à 4000 personnes
quatre mille soldats cyber soldats en
2000 en 2010 est la même chose pour les
israéliens les iraniens pour les ongles
et les russes les français mais
également il y à des actions civiles
comme on a ici des réservistes de
l'armée il y à des cyber réservistes et
des réservistes des cyber armée ça veut
dire des ingénieurs comme vous et nous
qui des ingénieurs qui ont des
compétences dans le domaine de
l'informatique des réseaux et qui
participent à des exercices de
cyberdéfense des exercices de
cyberattaques et qui sont prêts le jour
on va les appeler et les rapatriés pour
réaliser des actions
donc c'est l'exemple par exemple 2 du
plan réserve citoyenne en france il y a
un exemple très intéressant de la
cyberdéfense unit en lettonie donkey
groupes de la société civile et l'armée
en tunisie
nous avons un petit club qui s'appelle
sécurité qui a été créée par donc en
dans les fondateurs s'en lasser par mois
2010 on voit quelques uns aussi qui a
créé et qui a été créé en 2004 qui s'est
transformée après en une association et
qui a formé depuis 2004 jusqu'à
maintenant pratiquement 1000 ingénieurs
1000 ingénieurs sont aujourd'hui formés
ils connaissent les concepts de la
sécurité il y en a beaucoup aujourd'hui
qui sont des responsables dans dans les
sociétés tunisiennes et qui porte la
charge de la sécurité de la
cybersécurité de ces entreprises là
alors maintenant parlons des cyber armes
donc on a les cyber armes une cyberarme
c'est un code c'est un code malveillant
c'est un programme mais ça peut être
aussi une arme classique comme par
exemple le pote pour le f-35 lightning
ii de lockheed martin c'est un scénario
classique qui a des capacités capacité
de cyberattaques qui a été dévoilée la
semaine la semaine dernière par lockheed
martin
alors les programmes dont je vous
parlais on des actions très avancé ça
veut dire ils peuvent contourner les
mesures de sécurité ils peuvent se
connecter à des serveurs de commande
entre autre hall ils peuvent rapatrier
des données ils peuvent bouger d'un
ordinateur à un smartphone à un autre un
autre équipement ils sont extrêmement
sophistiqués l'efsc lignes de code
aujourd'hui de ce type de programme donc
cédé vingtaine de milliers de lignes de
code ça fait pratiquement 20 mégas il
est très loin des premiers virus qu'on a
vu celui qui supprime les fichiers ppt
doc ou celui qui supprime des images
c'est vraiment un grand écart entre les
deux les américains à travers la msa les
canadiens avaient à travers le centre de
la sécurité des télécommunications du
canada et les onglets à travers le gchq
ont développé des programmes aussi avec
ça veut dire une cible un cyber arsenal
2-2 d'outils qui permettent par exemple
de rediriger quelqu'un dans un flux par
exemple de prendre le contrôle de 100 de
sa machine par exemple de exploiter
certaines vulnérabilités pour brouiller
des pistes concernant les attaques qu'il
réalise donc les attal et les états ils
coordonnent entre eux pour se préparer
pour réaliser ce type ce type d' attaque
donc les armes et aujourd'hui se dote
d'action
ou de moyens défensif mais aussi de
moyens de moyens par dans défensif mais
aussi de moyens offensifs pour réaliser
des actions offensives
donc ce programme-là comptes où il se
base sur le programme de d'espionnage
delà de la nsa qui aujourd'hui en résumé
pour vous dire espionne au téléphone
espionne nos connexions internet nos
comptes facebook twitter yahoo skype les
connaît les téléphones iphone androïd
bas relief le musée le frigidaire ou le
gaz ou et encore j'ai encore des doutes
donc pratiquement ils collectent des
informations sur tout ce qu'on fait
pratiquement sur internet tous tout les
moyens de teknologik qu'on utilise et il
met sa à la disposition de la cia de
l'efs biya et des programmes militaires
américains ajoutant à cela
aujourd'hui le problème qu'on a c'est
dont nous avons trouvé l'année dernière
plus de 25 0 day ça veut dire des
vulnérabilités son correctif
ces vulnérabilités la existait depuis il
y en a certaines qui existait depuis 10
des dizaines d'années qui permettait par
exemple d'écouter le trafic de décrypter
les mots de passe de prendre le contrôle
d'un serveur linux et ça ça existait de
prix très longtemps elles ont été très
probablement utilisé par des services
secrets par les américains qui ont déjà
auparavant le la nsa a déjà pendant
plusieurs années injecter des back door
dans les solutions cisco les solutions
aux une hyper toutes les solutions qu'on
connaît qui sont maintenant brouiller ou
qui sont remplis de backdoor de
programmes qui permettent de nous
espionner et d'avoir de donner le
contrôle à des personnes à distance donc
la cybersécurité et la sécurité est elle
un échec
sommes-nous obligés aujourd'hui de
revenir au fameux 33-10 pour as pour
dire que nous sommes nous sommes
sécurisé pas totalement sur l'acier
aujourd'hui et c'est le thème du tedx
aujourd'hui la cybersécurité le domaine
étant actuellement en pleine
effervescence
ça veut dire qu'on est en train de nous
révisées nous mêmes pour trouver des
nouveaux concepts de nouvelles
techniques des nouvelles stratégies pour
défendre moi mon métier quotidien
1 c'est d'aider les entreprises à se
protéger à avoir trois choses la
capacité d'anticiper la capacité de
détecter et la capacité de réagir
je travaille pour des entreprises d'une
grande importance avec des centaines de
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
mais c'est un métier qui est extrêmement
intéressant où l'actualité est le
changement est pratiquement quotidien
les entreprises l'année dernière les
grandes entreprises dans le monde ont
investi plus de 1 milliard d'euros
l'année dernière dans les solutions et
les prestations de sécurité donc ça dit
ça veut dire que c'est un domaine qui
est extrêmement porteur pour tous les
jeunes qui sont ici
les états ont également ont changé de
tactique et comme ils voient que
plusieurs programmes solution sans
trouver par des parts départ des virus
et des programmes sont lancés dans ce
qu'on appelle les solutions souveraine
ça veut dire
ils développent leur propre système
d'exploitation ils développent leur
propre solution c'est une piste
incontournable aujourd'hui pour protéger
les organismes d'intérêts vitaux
les chinois ont développé câline qui est
leur propre système d'exploitation
les nord-coréens ont développé et
ratissent tard os les français clip les
les indiens les russes chacun il a son
propre système d'exploitation propre
solution de chiffrement y compris les
solutions les solutions de
systèmes d'exploitation y compris les
solutions de chiffrement dans deux ans
en 2017 inch'allah bonjour on compte on
reviendra ici je viens on viendra
sécurité souviendront vous parlez de
safe et karthago ce les premiers
systèmes d'exploitation tunisien
sécurisé merci beaucoup